good morning Hank it's Tuesday greetings
from extremely muggy Florida I have one
day off this month and you'll never
guess where I spent it leggo Vande this
place is great but I wouldn't
necessarily characterize it as relaxing
Hank I'm on i-4 in Orlando and I'm
remembering that like 12 years ago you
had a viral hit website called I hate I
4.com and it just it made me smile
anyway it's gonna take me a while to get
to the next place but I'm gonna use
movie magic to get you there quicker and
we've arrived just like that it took 45
minutes I have five minutes until my
runners world photo shoot that's right
I'm doing the photo shoot for the
magazine runners world I am now
literally a fitness model I mean so
majestic is that a middle-aged person or
a gazelle okay I have no your old high
school and I got to go sign some books
brief pause for book signing this paper
town they also got us t-shirts and
special green green room chairs and a
chair for our secret brother days but
most importantly they got Hanks high
school yearbook look a tiny baby
Hank look at high school yearbook photo
oh my god Brian Beck and Hank green
enjoy some quality time surfing the
quote net they believe that internet
privileges should be given to all
seniors Hank I agree hello and greetings
from the future because the rest of my
Orlando footage got corrupted we are now
in Nashville so think this has been an
awesome week we've performed in front of
more than 10,000 people including our
spouses and children and parents and
elementary school teachers Turtles all
the way down has reached number one on
Amazon's bestseller list it's also
gotten extremely generous reviews
including maybe the two best reviews any
of my books have ever received I'll link
to those in the doobly-doo below and
also reading people's incredibly
thoughtful responses to the book has
brought me to tears again and again this
week but it's also been a really
difficult week like my mental health to
speak frankly is not where I would like
it to be partly because I am so far
outside my usual routine and while I do
really love to tour and talk with people
about the book it's also a bit
overwhelming so I think I hope you'll
forgive this moment of sincerity but
watching you perform at your old high
school last night I kept thinking about
how incredibly kind you've been to me
the last few weeks like you're taking a
month away from your family and your
many jobs to be on tour with me
you turned your freaking Twitter profile
into actual Turtles all the way down and
you
just been there for me so consistently
in a way that frankly goes back to when
you were a student at that high school I
am really lucky and really grateful
thank you yeah that was way too much you
got to cut the sentimentality somehow
you got to say something mean about him
now not very good at cutting insults but
I know someone who is yeah let's say
something silly about Uncle Hank how
about that works thanks I love you Hank
you have a stupid butt that is a direct
quote from my four-year-old daughter
it's also kind of through with the
ulcerative colitis and everything I'll
see you on Friday
actually I'll see you like five minutes
from now